[Music]
welcome back guys to on base live in
your Bleacher Report app I am your host
Mookie Betts and today we have uh 22 I
call him 22 but his name is uh Clayton
Kershaw thanks for coming on bro thanks
for having me so real quick
for those who don't know Clayton Kershaw
because I was one that didn't know
Clayton Kershaw just hit Homer's off me
right before that I did it yeah okay so
um
he is a nine-time All-Star that's a lot
of All-Stars three-time Cy Young winner
NL MVP that's the one right there
let me tell you about that yes please
because all right that is ridiculous the
best players got hurt that's all it was
yeah but you were the best player no
Goldie got hurt
um McCutchen got hurt and Stanton they
all got hurt in this time right at the
right time to win MVP so yeah good
timing yeah it doesn't matter no I'll
take it though for sure doesn't matter
you still want to MVP I'll take it for
sure and then a 2020 World Series
champion yeah which we will touch on but
before we get to that I'd like to play a
little game
to get us in
um get us talking get the juices flowing
a little bit it's called on base off
base
either you're entering or out okay so
first I want to start with uh
do you believe in ghosts
I read about you mooc um
you know what I think off base on that
one I don't believe in Google so let me
I love the Fister by the way great okay
so let me explain
I did get an Airbnb
with my boys
and
um I did try to avoid the office the
Fister I'm not I'm not you know running
from that but I don't know that I'm
fully
scared of ghosts I just
don't want to find out yeah I get that
you know what I'm saying I get that
because if it is I'm scarred for life
and I may be scarred for life already I
think a little bit for Me Maybe is just
kind of curious too like I wanted to see
maybe you know yeah I want to see it but
yeah you know what I'm saying okay so
next thing Jumbotron memes you know
where I'm going with them are you in or
out on them I'm probably like can I be
half like yeah
honestly I I didn't even notice it until
after the game
yeah no none of us saw it but uh uh what
I said the next day is true is like if
you don't like if you don't like it you
just gotta pitch better yeah just just
play better that's the other perspective
right you know that that's the the
perspective like you know what I gave
them the reason to put it up there
exactly so um and I know it's never
coming from like our peers you know it's
never it's coming from somebody that you
know runs a job we we unders we
understand yeah you know the game is
tough yeah that got uh that went got
pretty viral there people people are mad
so I appreciate that thank you
appreciate it what about um like do you
have what about pregame superstitions
like you in or out on them or do you do
you think they you know yeah I think my
teammates would say I'm on base for this
one I just consider it more of I just
consider myself routine oriented okay so
but conversation yeah but if you get if
if one or two things go wrong in that
routine is it I've I'm a lot better than
I used to be yeah yeah I'm a lot better
than I used to be
um so yeah I think some people would say
I'm on base for that but I like to think
of it just as routines so so from what I
see
you know we'll talk about it later all
right so what about uh do you think the
Dallas Mavericks will win uh before the
Cowboys like are you oh no I don't think
that I think the Cowboys are closer
um I'm so I'm off base for that the
Mavericks are fun to watch though I went
to a few games this off season
um Luke is fun to watch when they got
Kyrie man they uh they can score some
points it's just they might need
somebody to play a little defensive yeah
hopefully they hopefully they find that
speaking of of Kyrie and Luca you got a
nice little jumper yourself thank you
you noticed that yeah yeah a little
Lefty stroke man I liked it I can shoot
that's the one thing I can do
all right but uh before we before we
learn really kind of how you got to the
big leagues learn about 22. um I do want
to say uh give you a special thank you
bro for for all that you do
um especially being with us right now
coming on the show I know uh you know
the family situation you had um mom
passed and uh so I do uh do want to
thank you and how you've handled it it's
been amazing bro so I appreciate it no
happy to do it this will be fun yeah
yeah so all right
so let's kind of get into how you became
a goat
um tell us about growing up you grew up
in Texas they breed after everybody
knows if you're from Texas you're good
at football basketball baseball you good
at everything but
um before we talk about baseball you
grew up with Matt Stafford yeah Matthew
and I grew up together
um played all the sports together
growing up Matthew is a way better
baseball player than I was a football
player and he uh he definitely could
have gone to college
um to play he's a shortstop and then he
like closed every once in a while for
our high school team and he quit after
his sophomore year to keep playing
football obviously uh probably the right
decision but yeah he was he was good at
baseball man he was really good so so
did y'all play Summer Ball together too
yeah we played Summer Ball together
y'all are tight we were tight growing up
yeah absolutely and then you know high
school he started playing more football
so I didn't see him as much but
um yeah we grew up together did all the
stuff is it cool that y'all were in La
together yeah it was fun it was uh I got
to go the Rams I got to go to the Super
Bowl and see him win and you know when
he was in Detroit we didn't get to see
him play that much you know so
um it's been fun we've been texting more
and
um he's been out to a couple Dodger
games so yeah it's been great yeah I
mean we won Rings what a year or two
apart I think just the next year they
won yeah yeah yeah so that's kind of
cool yeah because it took a while for
both of us to be able to get to there so
um that is that is pretty cool and you
got Scotty sheffler Scotty I don't know
Scotty Superbowl he's a good bit younger
but
um I've gotten to meet him once and he
seems great and he can golf man yeah
yeah he's winning right now too is he
yeah I think so I know he was up okay
yeah so you don't talk to him though
like we don't yeah we don't talk a whole
lot but he uh yeah did you see the
weather there today it was so bad is it
No One's Gonna score today so he might
stay up there well no one would score
him before it was so bad it's worse
today too okay make sure I check it out
yeah all right so you got drafted in 06
and then you debuted in 09 or 08 I'm
sorry yeah how was that like how was
going through the minor leagues because
I'm in two years I mean well really a
year and some change like you kind of
yeah no it was uh it was fun man you
know minor leagues is a good time
um because you just don't know any
better you know I didn't go to college
so I didn't have that college experience
so that was like my college experience
and then
um yeah I got called up when I was 20 so
I was young and you know you didn't have
to be like a finished product like now
like when we see these guys like Gavin
coming up and I'm sure we'll see Bobby
Miller come up at some point for the dot
like you have to be really good now you
know and back then I walked the house I
only had two pitches and one of them was
never a strike and I got sent down a
couple times so I was definitely needed
a little work but I honestly I've always
be thankful uh to Joe Torre for that Joe
was on my manager and Joe kind of let me
figure it out take my lumps and
um I think it made me better but you but
like now the game has changed so so much
so much and like now if you come up
and you have two pitches and one's not a
strike you're gonna be down so fast yeah
yeah like there's I just don't think a
guy can can make it I know I didn't but
yeah definitely not now you know well I
mean you're doing just fine yeah so the
next year in 2009 I uh I started the
year bad again in May Donnie Mattingly
was our hitting coach and Joe was still
a manager they called me in the office
and they basically said hey if you don't
find another pitch you're gonna get sent
down and you're not gonna be back until
you learn it this is a fastball
curveball yeah so fastball curveball so
that day I threw a bullpen and I started
throwing a slider and I've thrown a
slider ever since yeah is that that one
day and then I took it into the game two
days later and yeah I thankfully I mean
that's when I started getting better so
so so so so so you get pissed yeah if
someone calls it a cutter yeah cutter is
just a bad fastball man okay so this is
a slider because I I mean everybody
calls it a cutter I'm okay with it now
but for me it's just a mindset for it oh
yeah because I don't want it to go that
I don't want to go sideways I want to go
down so yeah yeah because when I face
you in live VPS that thing it just it
disappears bro that's the goal is to
like make the fastball go there and the
slider kind of go down right off of it
then
a cutter to me I've seen so many guys
get wrapped up and throwing Cutters that
they lose their good fastball so you
know I just it's just more of a mindset
but yeah I get mad at people sometimes
then you got the curl so like
is was the curveball like do you really
believe in like a staple I kind of like
wayno's curveball like ooh buenos
curveball you know yeah like have you
embraced The Kershaw curveball yeah but
it's fun I mean I definitely have thrown
a curveball my whole life and that's
it's I've thrown it that way since I was
11 years old it's been the same
um
but I don't throw it like I don't throw
it that much you know and I just don't
throw it for a strike as much as like a
guy like wayno does or something like
that so it's definitely an important
pitch for me and I definitely like you
know Vin Scully probably made it like
okay a big deal because Vin called it um
what do you call it Public Enemy Number
One I think which was
um which was funny but you know when Vin
says anything it's gonna be it's gonna
get a name of its own like when he
called Puig the Wild Horse yeah you know
it just it just takes off so I think
ever since then it kind of had like a
little thing of its own but yeah I
really don't throw it that much no no
you don't but you throw it when it's
needed when it's needed so has it been
cool playing for the Dodgers the whole
your whole career I think so man it's
been it's a special group yeah you know
I think the Dodgers I mean what do we
what do we want as players we want we
want a chance to win every year
and we want an organization that kind of
Embraces
what you want to be off the field and so
I think I think both of those things
they do a great job of and
um you know when the new ownership group
came I think it was like 2012. we PR we
saw a drastic change yeah you know they
started spending money making upgrades
and getting good players and so you know
ever since then it's been it's been
pretty special I will say that my
experience here
um you know in Boston was very similar
yeah but you know just being here now
being you know that that made it a
little easier to to sign you know my
deal here is just like you're gonna be
able to win every year yeah like you
said I mean they're gonna go get no no
fun to lose no no fun to lose and they
and our ownership group hates losing the
same way right you know so which that's
that's super that's super dope so
um and has it been has it been
um
not tough tough is the wrong word I
can't think of what word I'm looking for
but just be in the face of a franchise
for like 16 years bro well that's why
you're here
um I I just I'm just thankful I've
gotten to be here as long as I have and
I don't want to be here if I'm not any
good anymore you know I don't want to
just stick around to stick around so
um I still love pitching I still have a
great time doing it I still have fun
with the guys I still love hanging out
with everybody and so as long as I can
still get enough people out to make it
worth it I hope I can continue to do it
but
um it's been a it's been a fun run in La
man and it's a second home to me now my
family's been there
um you know my I've got four kids now
and they've grown up there too and my my
son is just now getting old enough to
like go to the field and enjoy it a
little bit so you're throwing them
throwing with him out there yeah man so
it's uh it's been that's been really fun
it's been a new little perspective for
me so it's been fun what tell me tell me
about like
you know the confidence you've had you
personally have to have
to worse Skechers on the map you know
what I'm saying like you are a very
confident person how did that happen bro
Skechers they they've been great they
have been awesome how did they did how
did they make a tweet like where did
this come from so Under Armor man I've
been I was under armor my whole career
and they uh they just stopped making my
cleat and so I had enough for a few
years after and I kept trying new cleats
of theirs in the interim and I was like
man this just don't feel right like they
don't feel right and so I went a full
year without any shoes and
um the guy that helps me out in La his
name's Bill he he reached out to
Skechers and they said oh we can we can
make a cleat for him and sure enough
they did and like it felt amazing and so
I was like you're going for feel like
yeah
I mean I'm not saying schedule hey I
think the spikes look great have you
seen them this year no they look great
honestly the only time I see your spikes
they look so good the only time I really
see your spikes is when I go in the
training room on the day you pitch you
gotta break them in and you are fully
dressed at four o'clock
that 20 tiles behind you laying back
sleep with your shoes untied it's my nap
time and you got everybody tiptoeing in
there not to wake Kersh up
and I walk in there like I be quiet but
then when I leave I'll be talking again
see that's routine that's not
Superstition that's routine okay all
right call it whatever you want to call
it so but man they've been they really
have been great and uh I think the
design each year has gotten better and
hey Maybe not maybe not a Jordan guy but
a lot of guys out there have been
telling me that they want to try them
and there's been a couple guys Wade
Miley's wearing skills yeah wait a
minute we got some guys so you can
you're the Pioneer maybe maybe if they
want to break into baseball I think
sketcher's good for sure why don't you
you need to head if they want to do it
I'm in I'm good all right okay all right
so I okay so I also want to ask you
because there's this big myth and my
opinion it's a big myth that you know
going through postseason you haven't
pitched well in postseason and to me
it's like well I mean I'm pitching in
the seventh and eighth inning
a lot of the times of course I'm going
to give up you know not give up but like
it's only a matter of time you know what
I'm saying especially how many times you
get there every situation is different
and I think every year that I've had
been in the postseason has been
different
um
at the end of the day it's not an excuse
whether you pitch in on short rest out
of the bullpen like you're just you just
have to do whatever the team needs you
to do and
um yeah I've definitely I've had some
good games and I've definitely come up
short too and that's that's everybody
yeah it's it's hard I mean it's hard to
you know say but at the end of the day
that's just part of being a pitcher and
um I'm thankful that I've gotten a post
I'm thankful that the teams needed me to
go out there and uh continue to go out
there and sometimes it hasn't been good
but
um and hopefully we get another chance
this year is it is that a different
mentality like is it a different I mean
it people say it's a different game
and it it kind of is to a certain degree
but it also is the same thing yeah I
think I think the things that changed is
that the bullpens are just yeah a lot
better yeah you know like you're facing
all the difference yeah like these guys
you you throw six Innings most teams in
the playoffs have three guys that are
you know just dominant so you have to be
basically perfect to get through seven
now and that wasn't the case back then
which is which is fine but it's
definitely not the case now no now I
mean I mean I think it was the Yankees
team in ah 2017 16 17 the the all they
had to do was go five right and then it
was yeah sixth seventh eighth ninth and
you know so but uh but not for you bro
you you you you go through all that yeah
I do one of MVPs bro there's nobody in
the bullpen that's gonna be better than
you you know what I'm saying and I'm
thankful for that I you know at the end
it's been it's been like a rocky road on
how to handle all that you know all the
coverage of postseason stuff but I've
come to peace with it and obviously 2017
didn't help with all the Astro stuff or
whatever but
um I think since then I've I've kind of
come to peace with it and at 2020 we we
brought it home we brought it home how
was that yeah that was great man that
was such a I want to hear from your
perspective because you think how about
like you'd already won one so you kind
of knew but like
um I don't think you realize the like
the big rock on your back you know the
big burden like I felt such like a
exhale like that was the first thing I
felt I was in the bullpen like just in
case and
um as soon as Julio got that last out
and I was running out there I just like
felt like I could breathe you know and
man it's such a relieving feeling
obviously I'm happy and joyful but I had
a lot of relief I really did so you you
played 16 years yeah and I'm not trying
to retire you bro good you can
um we got you got all stars the psy
Youngs the MVPs the World Series is
so like what what keeps you going now
bro like like you know you kind of want
everything and you know for me for me is
it like I you know I've kind of done a
lot of things in baseball and I got like
nine years left you know what I'm saying
so I want to be I want to become a Hall
of Famer just like you you know what I'm
saying and so that's kind of what I play
for and then my family my boys I'm not
our you know family my boys you know the
team and everything so that all matters
right I'm not that doesn't discount that
but like for for me personally it's like
you know what I want to become a Hall of
Famer so like what is it for you you
know what I my personal Legacy doesn't
matter to me okay never has I I don't
really care what people think of me on
the field the the two things that I've
always wanted was I really like to win
so I think that keeps me coming back and
then the respects of my peers in the
clubhouse like I love I love going to
the clubhouse and knowing that these
guys we're all in it together to do one
thing and we're all on the same page and
um there's like a respect there with
that I've always appreciated that in the
game is that nobody understands what we
do every day and so when you have when
you're playing other teams or you know
when you're when you see guys that you
play against and
um you know when we're in the clubhouse
together like that like mutual respect
of your peers is something that means a
lot to me yeah so between that and
trying to win a World Series those are
like my two big things that I want to do
I just want to keep winning so are you
going to play like men's league or
something
I think there's different I think
there's different degrees of winning the
only thing that's been a little pricing
post career is I've played with a couple
guys from Japan uh Hiroki Kuroda kinta
maida and they both said anytime I want
to go play first base in Japan I can go
play first base you rake bro I don't
know about rake but I think that would
be so fun to get to play first base you
might as well take the fam you go for a
year you know go for a year or two
I think it would be so much fun I don't
think Ellen would go for it but I think
it'd be a blast
yeah if she ain't going you ain't going
no that's true about that so let me ask
you so this year's team
has been a great team bro it's been this
has been this has been final we've we've
had a lot of fun
[Music]
um group of guys is amazing
um so and you know pretty much everybody
in the group of guys so let me ask play
a little game with you okay who is uh
most likely to to be a GM
be a GM uh maybe barnsey I agree with
that you agree yeah I think barnsey
might be I don't know now I don't know
what kind of GM but I see him being a GM
like I don't like when I say Khan like
is he going to be super cool or is he
going to be like no guys you need to do
you know I I don't know I think he's
gonna be like probably the guy that's
not talking to the media he is going to
talk to anybody okay I think no to the
media I think he's gonna be like the the
evaluator get stuff done guy I think he
could do it I think he'd be good at it I
I think he'd be very good at it yeah
because he's so good at calling games
and controlling games he's got a good
feel he's got great feel yeah so all
right so what about uh
show up late to an event
JD Martinez one thousand he's going to
be late every I don't know I've ever
seen him one time he's barely makes the
bus like if it's a 130 bus
I I really love getting to know JD he's
been great but not to call him out if it
is a 1 30 bus
he's not going to be there at 129. like
there's no buffer he's getting on that
he's getting on that elevator at 128.
and if they stop at a couple floors he's
going to call and say hey I'll be two
minutes late yeah nobody wait every
single time yeah it's just yeah that's
how it goes all right so who to sing the
loud house at a karaoke bar man
depending on the day
maybe Freddie I think Freddie would be
so much I think Freddy yeah yeah we'll
leave that alone so what about pickup
tab at dinner
I think we have a good group for that I
think there's plenty everybody would do
yeah I think there's I think especially
some of the guys that have been around
um you know you'll do it I'll do it for
you'll do it I think we got enough yeah
okay we got it we got it actually Jay
hey might be the main one I think he may
yeah in Chicago that was amazing what he
did for us the steakhouse and yeah and
then going to his facility that was
really which is super cool yeah that's
where I saw the Lefty jumper
um we got to uh so smooth
all right so let me ask you this
right now
give me your your top five
toughest at bats okay I think I've got
to face two of them tomorrow oh okay
Nolan's definitely up there aronato's
definitely
um he gets me man he's uh he's a really
tough out Goldie Goldie's super tough
um
who else is up there that I can't get
Manny Manny Manny yeah Manny Manny gets
me pretty good I just scare sometimes
scarce know like I ain't trying to talk
yeah but like I'd be like Manny come up
I'm like he just hasn't gonna throw him
right here I know Manny especially when
he's going good he's uh
there's not really like most guys have
like strength and weaknesses you know
where like you can't just throw it to
the weakness every single time but like
in big spots there's some safe zones
where you can go
Manny when he wants to can kind of hit
whatever yeah just depending on what
he's looking for so you kind of gotta
think along with him and he's pretty
good at that he's got good baseball
field and playing with him for a couple
months there in 2018 got to see it but
now having to face him so much for the
Padres you really see it how many is
that three
two more
do you have answers Dexter Fowler you
remember Dexter oh God Dex deck really
when he was in Colorado I don't think I
ever got him out wow yeah look up the
numbers are bad I want to see that yeah
not a lot of not a lot of homers but
just like hit after hit after Dex will
like that too okay you're welcome like
that yeah yeah like that for sure that's
cool all right one more
I haven't faced a lot of guys in the ale
yet like uh judge or uh vladi like I
don't face those guys enough yeah I face
I face he's obviously really good
um so I don't but I mean that's not a
that's not a shot though like the
toughest because matchups are a thing
right I know sometimes it's those guys
that are like the platoon righties that
get in there like
um like Austin Slater with the jokes uh
Wilmer floor like those guys like rough
yeah it's rough excuse me yeah honestly
tatis gets me too so there's plenty of
guys on there so but solid four though
okay and um the other day
you got hit by with a pitch clock
violation yeah what happened
I think I think I covered I think I
covered first base and was tired oh I
needed a minute so what do you do you
like the pitch block I think it's
overall yeah I do it's cool I two and a
half hour games are cool those are yeah
yeah those are cool so there's certain
moments in the game
um you know if you're struggling or if
you got a bunch of guys on base you want
to take a deep breath for a second and
you're like man I can't do that like
that's the only couple times where I'm
like man I'd like to you know not throw
a pitch right here but for the most part
I think it's probably been pretty good I
think I think it's been really really
really effective because we played yeah
Extra Inning game
and it was like three twenty or three
still wasn't five hours yeah exactly
what I'm saying so it so you're cool
with it and all the other rules you're
cool with yeah what are some of the
other ones the shift and all those type
of things yeah I haven't noticed have
you noticed big differences
um not big differences but some
differences some some like sure Knox few
extra knocks yeah I'm okay with it yeah
yeah I mean the Dodgers are really good
at shifts like I think it's a
competitive Advantage so I think some
teams are hurting more than others yep
but
if if like the goal is we need more more
hits more action less strikeouts and
that's going to make guys want to put
the ball in play more than as for as far
as like the betterment of the game I get
that I think I did that all right bro so
let me ask this I got uh
some fan questions all right
um
who's the funniest teammate you've ever
had as a Dodger Juan Uribe
all right tell me a one story I don't
know if I can on camera not that story
you don't have anyone okay what would he
do what would he do he would he would
dance all the time okay he uh
he's got good like he talked he speaks
really well right yeah when he wants to
yeah he's he's so funny he would so we
had a pretty good I think this was 2013.
um we had a really good bench crew we
had uh okay skip Schumacher Nick Punto
Michael Young Jerry Hairston
um
AJ Ellis like this big this great bench
group and uh AJ might have been a
starter then so sorry if I called you
bench guy but uh
uh and Juan man he would just he would
make so much fun of skip and Nick and
they would give it back to but like that
that was some and it was just so good it
was just I can't tell any stories but it
was just so good so good all right so uh
who who was one hitter you'd like to
strike out former or current it doesn't
matter former or current
um
foreign
I don't know was there a good answer to
that uh it could be it could be anybody
like our face let's say who who would
you like to face oh okay
um I like face Berry bonds
yeah I like to he retired in 2007. I got
called up in 2008 so I missed him
um
him and Griffey both I think retired
right before I got in and and you would
like to face it yeah like just to see
just to see yeah I like to see I wanna I
would you know what I would like to
watch that I wouldn't like to to be the
pitcher and actually do it because I
feel like
it's a helpless feeling when you don't
when you like I can't throw anything up
here I know yeah what is that like like
when you're like okay if you're facing
uh yeah what if you're facing doesn't
matter who yeah and you're like I don't
know what pitch to throw them yeah the
biggest thing with any pitch that you
throw is just be convicted so sometimes
you gotta trick yourself you know like
does that really work sometimes I mean
it's better to be like it's better to be
uh screw it I'm just gonna throw this
pitch as hard as I can and like he's not
gonna hit it and just as opposed to like
oh man maybe if I paint one on this
corner I can get him to take it you know
like so how hard is that yeah sometimes
mentally sometimes it's hard when it's
not going good and you know you feel
like every pitch you throw up there
because the second you think they're
gonna hit a pitch they're gonna hit it
they're gonna hit it yeah so sometimes
you just gotta say look man I'm gonna
throw this with all the conviction I
have and he's not gonna hit it and who
cares where it goes let's just see what
happens you know and sometimes it
doesn't happen a lot but I think more
often than not that mindset is way
better than like oh let's try to nibble
a corner or let's try to you know that's
not a good mindset to have so so
what how do you feel like if you throw
your pitch like oh I'm confident throw
the pitch yeah Homer
what like yeah I mean that's not ideal
yeah because it happened right but what
have you are you like oh my God like
what do I do it doesn't happen a lot
okay it doesn't happen if you if you
make your pitch you might get some you
might give up some hits like you know
good hitters hit good pitches sometimes
but
I would most of the time home runs are
mistakes
[Music]
they're mistakes like you know like it's
hard to hit pitches that are painted out
of the ball you might get a hit yeah but
it's hard to hit homers on pitches that
are paying you know we don't get paid to
hit those yeah yeah the best ones don't
miss the mistakes right yeah exactly so
but you're the and the best ones don't
throw the mistakes yeah and you try not
to sometimes you do you have a lot of
homers get away with it yeah but at the
end of the day like sometimes the solo
Homer is not a big deal no it's no but
like
25 pitch Innings and walk into guys and
giving up no runs yeah
potentially that can be worse yeah you
know so it's just like managing the game
and
um just competing man you just got to
compete that's why this game's so great
like it's a team sport but at the end of
the day it's me versus you for two
minutes then we do it again you know and
um competing it's it's fun okay I still
got another question uh
besides your nap tell could you tell us
your exact game day routine so I could
do that because like I know at at 5 32 I
do this no 5 38 I can do that too yeah
okay
um yeah I mean I'll start from like
I get there I get there relatively early
on start days I get there around like 1
32 so I can eat lunch because I'm not
hungry on when I pitch so like I gotta
eat early and then uh normally their
lineup has come by then okay so I'll go
uh I've already done all the scouting
but I'll go make sure that there's no
guys that aren't playing that are
playing or something like that and once
I feel good about how I'm gonna get guys
out I'll uh the one thing that I've
always done is I throw this ball against
the wall yeah I I always do and
um is that just getting the feel yeah
okay yeah there's you can't just go out
there and rip a thousand curve balls a
day you know but to flip curveballs
against the wall one hop and cat like
you can do that all day so I'm
constantly doing that I do that a couple
times
um do you do sliders like that yeah so I
do it all I do every pitch and uh so
that yeah I've always done that and then
at five o'clock we have a little meeting
um okay so from one to you from one four
o'clock I take a nap all right four
o'clock yes I got my cleats on I'm on
the training table I'm lying down
everybody's tiptoeing yeah
okay so and then and then at five
o'clock you have your meeting a little
meeting that takes like
10 minutes max okay yeah and then I'll
go down the weight room and warm up
558 heat packs heat packs of 558 okay
623 go out on the field okay
6 40. play catch
at home finish before the anthem so 657
finished warming up and then 708 and go
out of the field
that's good to know is it okay no just a
708 part
all right so let's go back to the game I
want to go back to the other game
uh when I said like who's most likely
right yeah who's like what about losing
a fantasy football league who's going to
be that who's going to that was me for a
long time you but not but you got to
delegate you got to find the right
partners and you did I did you won I won
two year two years ago I won three in a
row three in a row three in a row did
nothing financial backer only sometimes
that's all you guys it's so nice to just
bragging rights for the year is
incredible nobody can tell you anything
no I won it doesn't matter how I won
yeah so
um I love football I love watching I am
just not I don't know who the San Diego
Chargers at zachler actually it might
not be I don't know who's running back
you know like I don't know all that
stuff so it's like it's good to have
somebody that's in it you know okay so
so uh what about uh who would be most
like I would say this is probably me
though like be the Dugout DJ or Bic
either one DJ big dickulis is pretty
solid ridiculous that's what I call them
oh nice yeah okay all right yeah yeah
ridiculous no I'd give it to you though
you know what you're doing yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah big big plays music he he
don't use no words
I want to hear some lyrics I want to
hear something and so yeah that's just
kind of music he likes so yeah so what
about
um watch an entire Star Wars series in
one day
Tony maybe I think Tony would do that
yeah gunsling I think Tony would do that
it seems like he's into that yeah
hey back to music's such a big deal this
year for us I mean every year music's a
big deal but like like music in the
weight room is important like good vibe
in the weight room you might get more
people to work out good vibe in the
clubhouse and now the plane like music
is Big between DP
and migiro
that's a great relationship that's a
great relationship like Step Brothers
yes that's so good yes they're and
they're both they both DJ in the back of
the plane
um Mickey Rowe I would say is is the
better of the two but DP gets us hype
yeah DP DB's a crowd pleaser yeah yeah
so he he literally goes song the song
and tries to find something that like oh
I see uh you know oh I see months I'm
gonna try to play a good song for months
or like you know as opposed to like
having a playlist yeah yeah yeah and
Mickey's great makes fun of them it's uh
they've been great ads this year they
really have I think they've really yeah
they've been really good a lot so what
about uh who uh will win a ping pong
tournament
I
you did beat me yeah I was just we only
played one game yeah yeah I would say
you though so you know who's good
Freddie's good Freddie's good barnsy's
good
um
bazooka's good graterol is good so I I
would still like to say me I'm
definitely not as good as I once was we
don't play as much we don't play as much
yeah kids get in the way but
yeah I think well we got our charity
event yep doubles ping pong July 27th
tell me about that doubles is different
though Doubles Doubles is different yeah
sure it's like the movement so yeah so
what who like I know you always have a
lot of stars yeah star-studded we've had
some good good uh good celebrity Sports
people come out it's always it's always
a fun night guys have a great time
um last year we had some sponsors win
they paid a bunch of money against play
and they won yeah okay so okay and so uh
do they get to come back I don't know I
it's more fun when like you know you see
like
like uh Brad Paisley or Ashton Kutcher
some of these guys win so we'll see
we'll see because the spot I remember I
remember talking about it and there that
that like she was with the woman she was
really good yeah she was almost a ringer
yeah she was really really good so
um I've been hurt a lot of these years
so I haven't gotten to play so hopefully
this year I stay in one piece and get to
get out there and have some fun be good
so yeah we'll we'll be fine and I'll uh
I'll definitely hedge the BET and find a
find the best one and play with play
with them so
so there's a uh a comment here from
skimmer
92929 they said my two favorite players
this episode is Blue Heaven thank you
skimmer
um and Kirsch I want to thank you for
coming on here man
um
I will just say being on the other side
and not knowing you not knowing who you
were or anything and then playing
against you that's how I really got to
know who Kershaw was because I didn't
watch baseball I didn't really watch it
I just played it yeah and um and then
when I got traded over here and you know
was hearing so many hearing so much
about you
I did and I didn't know who you were and
then I eventually got to know you got to
you know playing with you and well
you're you're a dope human bro
appreciate you super dope man you just
go with the Vibes you chill you leave
when you when you need to
um you chill when you need to you're uh
you're there for all the guys
um so I just I want to thank you for all
that you do for all of us and
um
hopefully you could play another couple
years man I don't know we'll see we'll
see how to how the left arm yeah holds
up but uh thank you for coming on
episode number two thank you man this is
fun this is great I enjoyed it see you
guys later on all right
[Music]